viviane j'étais en train de tapoter ma
tasse de café comme tafer dans sa
dernière vidéo
j'ai trompé ma tartine dans ma tasse de
café
et là ça fait des gouttes super bizarre
où commence à des trucs bizarres des
gouttes et bien figure toi que j'ai
trouvé des chercheurs qui ont étudié ça
il ya des chercheurs qui travaillent sur
la science de la tartine beurrée alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des chercheurs de grenoble se sont
intéressés à la forme et à l'évolution
de certaines routes que l'on peut voir
se former à la surface d'un liquide
comme le thé ou le café lorsqu'il est
mis en contact avec un liquide gras
comme le beurre fondu
on voit des gouttes de gras qui
s'étendent très rapidement et si on
regarde bien on voit se former ce qui
ressemble à des trous à l'intérieur de
ces gouttes et ses trous semble être
éjecté
rassurez-vous les chercheurs ont bien
conscience qu'il s'agit d'analyser une
pratique très française est considérée
comme révoltante par certains
spécialistes du thé tremper sa tartine
beurrée dans sa boisson mais ce type de
phénomène peut aussi se retrouver dans
l'industrie lorsque deux liquides non
miscibles sont mises en contact
revenons à ma tartine dans le café les
chercheurs de grenoble ont décidé de
partir justement de cette constatation
pour appliquer toutes les étapes de la
méthode scientifique simplifier le
problème formuler une hypothèse élaboré
un protocole expérimental reproductible
confirmer ou pas l'hypothèse est relié
ce phénomène aux études existent rond
ils ont tout d'abord essayé de trier les
paramètres importants de ceux qui
n'avaient probablement que peu
d'influencé sur le phénomène est ce que
le café est important pour l'apparition
des gouttes
non ça marche aussi avec du thé de l'eau
chaude et même de la glycérine et sa
température
non donc le beurre est fondu en surface
est ce que la qualité de la matière
grasse est importante
oui ça marche seulement avec du beurre
et de l'huile naturelle ou etc etc
ils ont ainsi réduit leurs études à un
problème beaucoup plus simple une huile
végétale ou animale en contact avec de
l'eau et cela donne bien le phénomène
qui nous intéresse ensuite ils ont
formulé une hypothèse première étape le
beurre de la tartine fonds est créé des
grands doutes
or ces gouttes contiendrait certaines
impuretés aqueuse qui vont jouer le rôle
de tensioactifs ces molécules souvent
connu pour faciliter la formation entre
deux liquides non miscibles vous savez
c'est notre fameux liquide vaisselle wa
secret de printemps par endroits la
couche de gras devient très chine
or les impuretés qui sont présentes dans
la goutte se déposent peu à peu et
libère au contact du fond de la bouche
des molécules de tensioactifs à cet
endroit le gras perd son affinité avec
l'eau et un trou se forment et pour
expliquer le déplacement des trous les
chercheurs remarquent que les gouttes de
gras ont une forme de lentilles à la
surface de l'eau elles sont plutôt
bombay au centre est plus fine en
bordure ils en déduisent que les trous
se déplacerait vers les bords des
gouttes là où l'épaisseur de gras est
plus faible
voilà pour les hypothèses comment les
prouver maintenant et bien en réalisant
une expérience reproductible avec des
ingrédients strictement nécessaire et
des paramètres contrôlés
les scientifiques ont choisi de l'huile
végétale qu'ils ont filtré pour enlever
toutes les impuretés
puis ils ont ajouté une quantité connue
d'une molécule de tensioactifs produite
en laboratoire une solution de lauryl
sulfate de sodium et en déposant ce
mélange délicatement sur l'eau pas là
[Musique]
cette expérience créée le même phénomène
que le beurre de ma tartine dans ma
tasse de café
donc les chercheurs ont bien identifié
les bons paramètres et ils valident
ainsi leur hypothèse il montre que cette
expérience simple modélisant la tartine
dans le café reproduit une variété de
phénomène jusque là étudié séparément
il y a une forme de propulsion des
gouttes de grade lors de l'éjection des
trous il y à des gouttes qui dansent et
lorsqu'il ya assez de gras un film de
gras a percé d'une multitude de trous
peut se former couvrant la totalité de
la surface du liquide et vous pourrez
vous aussi facilement observer cette
figure en dentelle si vous plonger
directement une noisette de beurre dans
votre café le gras c'est la vie les
chercheurs montrent donc que ces gouttes
traversé par des trous sont une nouvelle
manifestation de ce que les physiciens
appellent les effets marangoni du nom du
physicien italien carlo malango ni des
phénomènes qui apparaissent à
l'interface entre deux liquides non
miscibles en présence de tensioactifs et
on en avait d'ailleurs fait une vidéo
qui s'appelle les gouttes qui pulse
l'étude de ces phénomènes est très
précieuse pour les professionnels de la
peinture de l'impression du revêtement
technique mais aussi de la cuisine car
elle permet d'améliorer les processus de
fabrication
donc en trempant leurs tartines dans le
café il ya quand même des chercheurs qui
ont mis en évidence un nouvel effet
mangoune c'est quand même fou c'est fou
ça c'était cet effet marangoni parce
qu'on le trouve vraiment à plein
d'endroits différents
et d'ailleurs je t'invite à venir voir
sur ma chaîne j'ai une petite
manifestation encore de ce même effet
mais qui est très esthétique
voilà pour cet épisode un peu spécial
qui montre que la méthode scientifique
peut s'appliquer pour analyser les
phénomènes du quotidien et qu'il n'y a
pas besoin d'en faire des tartines pour
faire des découvertes passionnantes
n'hésitez pas à aller faire un tour sur
la chaîne syllabus pour voir l'épisode
de viviane et profitez-en pour regarder
les gouttes qui pulse un autre épisode 2
est de science
est ce que le café est important pour
l'apparition des coûts